[Music]
[Applause]
he's Chris Sims pro football talk live
co-host you can see him and listen to
him on the show that precedes ours on
peacock with Mike Florio pro football
talk live and Chris joining us on the
program going into the games what was
the one where you thought we could see a
surprise it was the Green Bay Dallas
game right I didn't have the guts to
pick it if you listen to my podcast last
week me talking to Florio on PFT that to
me was the game where I went you know
out of all the games that there could be
a surprise this weekend right and I
didn't see the Houston Cleveland thing
coming that way but the the the the
Green Bay one was the one way went again
no Dallas had the better season but you
know anybody that watches football it's
a matchup league and there was some
things about Green Bay that I th
certainly posed some problems for Dallas
and thought they could keep it close if
not pull off the upset certainly didn't
see them blowing them out the way they
did that was pretty amazing okay are we
can we move on from Jordan love uh we're
not quite sure if he's that good or he
might be you had people who suggested
that he was a bust like this guy has
been unbelievable and they played
playoff football to get into the
playoffs and I Chris when they when they
won the toss and elected to take the
ball right it told me everything I
needed to know about Matt lefleur's
confidence in Jordan love and that
offense yeah that's right and Matt
laflor let's not forget was in Atlanta
with Dan Quinn right so he knows that
defense and I think they knew yeah
Jordan love right we can run the
football Dallas has a smaller defense
wait we got some weapons let's jump out
on Dallas early at home instead of
letting it be vice versa which Dallas of
course hasn't lost in two years
basically cuz they jump out on people
then the other team has to oh no we got
to throw the ball more than we'd like
and now Micah Parsons and the pass rush
get unlocked and they get to play from
ahead and they're dangerous that way
Dallas they're kind of like the bullies
once they start bullying you they just
kind of pound you in the ground Green
Bay said the hell with that we're not
going to let that happen we're going to
get out on front and we're going to make
you play a style of football you don't
necessarily love to play and just kept
the pressure on them consistently Jordan
love like you said I mean when he came
out in the draft there was a lot that I
really liked about him he was is raw and
that's where it's hard with the draft
right because you know you look at him
now and you go hey Jordan love watch out
he's got super he's got some superow
Superstar caliber traits he does his
ability to hang in the pocket not see
anybody around him throw off his back
foot he's got long arms and gigantic
hands he can flick it I mean what a
performance by him and Matt laflor and
the whole football team in Green Bay all
right let's troubleshoot the Cowboys
you're Jerry Jones right what are you
going to do
I I
mean it's it's a tough one right I I I
feel I guess there's a part of me where
I'm old school and I want to go man a
guy finished 12 and five for the third
year in a row right but also the
expectations are higher than that out of
the three playoff losses that McCarthy
has you know I think two of them they're
gonna Dallas is going to look at and go
we feel like we were the better team in
two out of the three losses the first
loss to the the 49 ners a few years ago
in the wild card game with the not being
able to spike the ball late and then of
course yesterday that always leaves a
sour taste at the owner's mouth wait I
think we're the better team yet we
didn't win any games in the playoffs and
didn't Advance that's going to be hard
for Jerry Jones to swallow you know I
think Jerry Jones really chopped out a
leg of Mike McCarthy's power over the
football team earlier this week by
saying hey we'll see how it goes week by
week in the playoffs that's a great
message just send to your locker room
about the general of your football team
in a big game right Dan I mean that was
kind of crazy and then of course Jerry
Jones puts high expectations out there
during the week going I think this is
our best chance in a long time all right
so all that I feel for Mike McCarthy but
at the same time I don't think it's
totally reached expectations and you
know clock management the way you think
they make a change Chris yeah I do I
think something drastic is coming I
think it's going to be
hard after all this for Mike McCarthy
and them to command the locker room I do
I just think with the way things have
kind of shake shook out his reputation
before that uh I think players in the
locker room no matter how well they do
next year they're still going to go in
the playoffs going wait is our coach
going to get us ready and I think that's
ultimately will lead to the end of the
Mike McCarthy era in Dallas but you also
have Bill bich available that's if you
don't if you don't have bich available
because you know you can fire your coach
but who were you replacing him with
that's the important part of this but
you do have the bill bich aspect that's
out there if bich not out there it do
you think Jerry Jones makes a change
maybe not you know I look at vyel to be
up in that category where I go wait Mike
vel's out there too right so but I I
mean I know it's bellich it's the
greatest coach of all time I think we
all Wonder can Jerry Jones and bellich
coexist as working Partners right I
think there's a relationship off the
field but you know is Jerry at a point
finally where maybe he's old enough and
desperate enough to go okay okay okay
okay I'll run the the press conferences
and the business and you can run the
football and I won't go as crazy with
the press conferences and give the state
of the union and I'll do all that if
they can find some common ground there I
think it's the exact type situation bich
is looking for right Dan bich doesn't
want to go somewhere and rebuild he's
not looking for that he's looking for
like what Tom Brady had when he went to
Tampa I'm going to look for a team
that's ready that just needs me to come
in and add a little Finishing Touch to
the the whole thing here and I think
that's where yeah bich will be very
enticing to the Jones family are you
sold on Dak making him the highest paid
player in the NFL with this contract
coming up well I I why does it have to
go that way always why can't it just be
towards the top of the market you know
that that's where I want to like some of
these teams got to stop negotiating
against themselves well the agents won't
allow that to happen I I I know that's
what you know with Dak and you know he's
made good money he's you can win a Super
Bowl with him he's certainly top 10ish
type of quarterback right he did a great
year uh I I still would want him to be
my quarterback right but I would go wait
no no you're you're not Joe burrow and
you're not Patrick Mahomes and you're
not Josh Allen so you don't get that
quite yet you got to earn that and
that's where I feel like you know they
got to draw a line in the sand a little
bit there and figure that one out and I
feel the same way with Chula and the
Dolphins well th throw out a number we
don't know to throw a big number out
there who's going to offer to a huge
contract I'm going to say nobody so you
know it'll be interesting to see how
both of those teams kind of handle that
situation this year yeah you know the
overreaction to these games and
certainly with Tua it's like oh you
can't sign him up for a long-term
contract I'm like why can't who are you
replacing him with I mean he he did have
a good year he stayed healthy um I
didn't think they had chance to beat
Kansas City and um no he's you're
exactly right that's the big question
for all these guys right like oh we're
going to replace Justin Fields we're
going to replace Dak Prescott like I I
you know if you're totally sold that you
got somebody better that you know is
going to come in and just knock it out
of the park okay fine but he better
because if he doesn't people like me are
going to go what the hell were you
thinking replacing that guy with that
guy okay and that's where yes it get
does get dicey you're right about that
and we'll see yeah you're you're
certainly right Tua had a great year
right no doubt about it you know as we
see when teams figure out a few of the
McDaniels tricks though they're limited
and Tu is not the type of guy that's
just going to go I'll carry the team and
I'll figure it out and I think this is
why the prior regime was had cold feet
on Tua because they felt like man cold
weather tough AFC January football we're
not sure he could throw through the
elements and carry an offense that way
and I think those questions still exist
after the other night Chris Sims pro
football talk live co-host also his
podcast called unbuttoned the former NFL
quarterback watching the Rams I thought
the Rams were going to beat the Lions I
did too I just think that momentum that
they had you know they were playing well
but that second half when you're just
kicking field goals came back to haunt
them and you know give give Jared gof
and Dan Campbell a lot of credit because
that's a game you're supposed to win and
they did win that's right and the
pressure was on them the expectations
the fans everything there right Jared
gof if there's anybody that was this
thing was personal to it's him right
Matthew Stafford like he he asked to get
out of Detroit he was ready for a change
he won a Super Bowl with the Rams Jared
G is like wait that team got rid of me
they gave the team that I'm on something
even more to make sure that they got rid
of me right so that was personal to him
good for him it's amazing what Dan
Campbell's done I think you said it
right right I was in this when the
second half started I was like man the
Rams got to figure something out on
defense because oh my gosh the Lions
just moving the ball up and down the
field they go on that long field goal
drive there to start the third quarter
but after that Rams defense settled in
gave them issues I think what you said
is the key to the game the fact that the
Rams kind of controlled the second half
moved the ball uh certainly were the
better team on the field I felt like in
the second half but couldn't punch it in
once they got down there in the red zone
that lions run defense came in handy and
then of course now McVey can't spread
the field out the same way inside the 10
yard line and it became tough for them
to to punch it in and that was the
difference in the game you're right
about that Dan all right handicap this
game uh these two games let me start
with the Steelers and the bills when a
game is moved you know back like you
have to wait another day what that does
to the preparation or getting like you
get in that game day mode and we're
going to be playing on Sunday and then
we're not playing and now we're playing
on Monday afternoon I don't know if it
messes with either of these teams but
I'm just curious of the Steelers going
into Buffalo what you expect to happen I
I I I think it it just makes more the
teams more antsy right I think they
found out early enough to where they
hadn't quite got into game mode yet uh
you know I think as the players some of
them are going to go man I'm going to
feel fresh this is great to have an
extra day to heal and get there you know
I think the coaches will look at it and
go hey there's a few things we can
Tinker with here and a little few extra
coaching points to help us out I think
we're going to see a a a tough cold
weather type of football game that the
bills kind of control but it's ugly
right I would expect like a
2713 type of win I just don't trust that
the Steelers offense can move the ball
consistently on this bills defense and
then you have Tampa at home as an
underdog Baker Mayfield banged up and
like maybe psychologically the Eagles
banged up I'm not sure what to expect in
this game I I it's it's to maybe the for
me the hardest game to figure out of the
weekend right I mean the the Bucks
they're going in like they're they can't
feel that great they got kind of
dominated by the Saints at home the
second to last week of the season last
week of the season they barely beat
Carolina it wasn't very impressive the
Eagles yeah like you said it's a pitiful
December I chose the Eagles because I
just think they're the more talented
football team now not having AJ Brown
that does change things too as well but
I think this is a close one I think
we're going to see a lot of big plays in
the passing game uh I just feel like the
Eagles have a few more Avenues in which
they can kind of uh let the game Flow
too and there's a little more
versatility in their attack uh I'm going
to go with them but I I'm not feeling
like real confident I'm not betting any
money on DraftKings I'll tell you that I
this came to mind when I'm watching
Matthew Stafford get banged up last
night and we had the benefit of you know
that camera that focused on his face and
his
hands and I I I have to believe he was
concussed in that moment but what he did
is he grabbed his ribs so if you grab
your ribs when you go to the sidelines
they put him in the tent they may not
even be checking him for a
concussion yeah yeah I mean it do you
think Matthew Stafford had the
wherewithal to be able to go oh my God I
got my bell rung oh man do my ribs hurt
I think 100% you know I I'm not sure
that's what happened and maybe his ribs
are hurt he hit the ground hard right
I'm with you you saw the eyes wide open
all that now you know you get hit like
that sometimes like your eyes are like
that anyways cuz you're like holy crap
that was that was a car wreck I can't
even believe am I alive still right
there's a little of that that goes on in
your head there but I think to your
point the players are conditioned my
bell got run run
let me lay here a second so I don't
stand up and become wobbly and then they
definitely take me out of the game and I
would do the same thing Dan if I Bell
got wrong I'd be grabbing my shoulder
and my arm to distract from it right
away because it's a big game and I want
to play and you're not telling me I'm
not playing man my shoulder hurts even
though I'm seeing three of you and I I
would not be shocked if he pulled that
move I think that is something that the
players are very aware of okay but if
you have the wherewithal to grab your
ribs then maybe you're not concussed
that well that's see that's what a
player would say and a player would go
yeah it's just my bell rung I'm not
concussed it's football I got hit hard I
don't need concussion protocol here and
see that's what I think an old school
player like Stafford is going to justify
it like hey I was smart enough to fake
it I'm not that out of it and hey did
you see that throw I made and the
decision I made on next Drive I was fine
I made some great plays and all that uh
Rams you know Future's bright they did a
great job of retooling this team and and
kept they got a o line finally there
kyen Williams is a superstar running
back puka is a superstar incredible job
this year and watch out for them in the
future here thank you bud good to talk
to you as always thanks Dan be good see
you everybody Chris Sims you can see him
on football night in America pro
football talk with Mike floro he's the
co-host that show precedes ours